buongiorno a tutti
una circa 30 anni fa quello che sapevamo
riguardo al cervello era che dopo la
nascita
soltanto in un brevissimo periodo che
veniva chiamato periodo critico il
nostro cervello aveva la possibilità di
modificarsi
ma dopo quel periodo il nostro cervello
rimaneva statico anzi non solo quello
che noi sapevamo era che man mano che
andavamo avanti nel corso degli anni il
nostro cervello parte valeva numero di
neuroni in pratica quindi andando verso
l'invecchiamento
noi non facevamo altro che perdere e non
le neuroscienze però negli anni hanno
fatto enormi progressi in particolare
c'è denunciano aiuto anche la tecnologia
con le nuove neuroimmagini risonanza
magnetica risonanza magnetica funzionale
noi adesso abbiamo la possibilità di
vedere anche quello che succede nel
nostro cervello in b.go e quello che
sappiamo oggi è una cosa importantissima
si è superato un dorma che vi ripeto
sembrava inflessibile
noi oggi sappiamo che non solo il nostro
cervello non è statico ma sappiamo che
il nostro cervello e plastico ovvero il
nostro cervello ha la possibilità di
modificarsi lungo tutto il corso della
nostra esistenza
dal giorno in cui nasciamo al giorno e
collaboriamo come si modifica il nostro
cervello ci sono fondamentalmente tre
meccanismi attraverso i quali si
modifica il cervello
un primo meccanismo è un meccanismo
chimico
ci sono poi dei veri e propri
cambiamenti strutturali e ci sono poi
delle notificazioni di tipo funzionale
per quanto riguarda i cambiamenti
chimici
noi abbiamo milioni di neuroni nel
nostro cervello sono le nostre cellule
qualunque nostro comportamento è
possibile proprio perché i neuroni tra
di loro
mandano il segnale che dicono poi cosa
dobbiamo fare come dobbiamo reagire
i neuroni comunicano l'uno con l'altro
attraverso le sinapsi queste sinapsi
sono innescate dal rilascio di un
neurotrasmettitore quindi un neurone
comunica con il neurone successivo
attraverso il rilascio di un
un trasmettitore più noi svolgiamo le
attività maggiore è la quantità di
neurotrasmettitore liberato maggiori
quindi sono le sinapsi che noi evochiamo
nel nostro cervello
facciamo un esempio io non suono il
piano ma mettiamo che adesso qualcuno di
voi voglia insegnarmi a suonare un
motivetto al piano io inizio dopo un'ora
la mia prestazione migliorata
io penso di aver imparato quel motivetto
domani mattina mi rischiato davanti al
piano e ahimè scopro che non è così
forse mi ricordo qualcosa ma il
motivetto io non lo so più suonare
perché è questo il primo punto per far
sì che la modificazione si stabilizzi
ci vuole pratica pratica pratica
l'apprendimento passa attraverso una
pratica costante quello che io ho
ottenuto quindi durante la prima ora era
una modificazione chimica o aumentato la
quantità di neurotrasmettitori ma non è
stato sufficiente per portare ad una
modificazione strutturale
un altro esempio i nostri neuroni non
funzionano quasi mai singolarmente il
nostro cervello lavora all'unisono
noi siamo in grado di evocare dei
circuiti neuronali ad esempio uno
stimolo a cui siamo esposti a lungo fin
dalla prima infanzia e poi nel corso
degli anni la mamma io ogni volta che ne
approccio a mia mamma
fin da piccolo la vedo e quindi in quel
momento mi si attiva la corteccia visiva
ma non solo sento il suo profumo è un
profumo particolare associato a mia
madre corteggio al fattiva la toccò al
tatto a un tanto particolari
corteccia tattile mise attiva e così via
il suono della sua voce corteccia
uditiva
tutte queste aree del mio cervello
funzionano insieme ogni qualvolta io
vedo mia madre perché questa è un'altra
cosa importante in neuroni che sparano
tra virgolette insieme cioè che si
attivano insieme poi si legano insieme e
questo spiega ad esempio perché ad un
certo punto mia mamma non c'è magari non
c'è più io cammino per la strada
improvvisamente sento un profumo quello
il profumo che utilizzava mia madre ed
improvvisamente mia mamma è lì io la
vedo la sento percepisco addirittura la
sensazione tattiche di quando la tocco o
di quando la toccavo perché perché è
stato sufficiente quella rievocazione
della mia protection fattiva per
attivare tutto il circuito cerebrale che
è collegato a quelle immagini quindi
l'immagine di mia madre
queste le dicevo sono però modificazioni
chimiche
abbiamo poi anche la possibilità di
provocare delle vere e proprie
modificazioni strutturali del nostro
cervello
una delle cose che noi sappiamo è che i
nostri neuroni ad esempio anche solo in
seguito ad una lesione cerebrale una
lesione cerebrale che può venire per un
trauma cranico
piuttosto che per un'emorragia un ictus
nelle aree per i lesionali cioè
immediatamente vicino alla zona
lesionata
quello che adesso noi sappiamo che
succede è che il nostro cervello
immediatamente si attiva per cercare di
riparare di supplire al danno quindi dai
nostri neuroni da gli assoni crescono il
fenomeno si chiama spr outing che sta a
significare germogliazione ovvero
crescono dei collaterali degli assoni
che vanno a causare nuove cena
per cercare di supplire al danno ma la
cosa più incredibile che oggi sappiamo
dalle neuroscienze rispetto al nostro
cervello e kate non solo nostro cervello
e plastico è vero che noi perdiamo
neuroni ma noi oggi sappiamo che c'è un
fenomeno che viene chiamato neuroscienze
o meno nel nostro cervello c'è la
possibilità che crescano o meglio
nascano nuove cellule cerebrali e di
nuovo questo avviene durante tutto il
corso della nostra esistenza si sono
provate le cellule si tratta di cellule
staminali di tipo toti potenti per cui
cellule in grado di trasformarsi sono
vengono chiamate baby cells cellule
neonate in grado di trasformarsi in
qualunque tipo di cellula cerebrale
non è un caso che la popolazione di
queste cellule staminali nell'uomo la si
è ritrovata all'interno di una struttura
particolare questa struttura e vedete
raffigurata qui è l'ippocampo
noi abbiamo tuo inserire cerebrale
abbiamo due ipo campi l'ipo caldo si
trova più o meno all'interno della
regione temporale del nostro cervello e
vi dicevo non è un caso probabilmente
che le cellule staminali quindi la
possibilità di neurogenesi sia proprio
all'interno dell'ipo campo perché
l'ippocampo e la struttura cerebrale
deputata alla formazione dei ricordi
quindi riguarda tutto il nostro
apprendimento ma vediamo quindi come noi
possiamo potenziare questa plasticità
cerebrale vi mostro un primo esperimento
è stato più volte replicato prendiamo
alla nascita una popolazione di ratti
tutti uguali quindi geneticamente simili
hanno tutti lo stesso patrimonio
genetico
poi suddiviso in tre condizioni
sperimentali diverse in tre gabbie in
una gabbia metto un unico atto isolato
in un'altra gabbia invece metto un
gruppo di ratti quindi condizione
sociale ma non solo in questa gabbia
metto tutta una serie di strumenti
cognitivamente stimolanti per dei ratti
ma anche vedete delle ruote delle
squadre delle scale tutti i degli
stimoli che permettono ai ratti di fare
molto movimento quindi esercizio fisico
e infine da bravi ricercatori abbiamo
sempre una condizione di controllo c'è
una gabbia dove di ratti ne metto due e
non isolato ma senza nessuno di questi
strumenti
lascio ai ratti in queste gabbie per un
periodo identico circa un mese dopo
quattro settimane
cosa succede vado a sacrificare la
ghirotti ea studiare i loro cervelli
quello che le scopriamo è incredibile i
ratti che sono stati inseriti in quella
che viene chiamata condizione arricchita
cioè ricca di stimoli sociali altri
ratti ricca di stimoli cognitivi e ricca
di stimoli che permettono di fare del
movimento hanno un cervello che pesa in
maniera significativa di più rispetto al
ratto che è stato messo in quella che
viene chiamata condizione impoverita ma
non solo
nel cervello di questi ratti attraverso
una misura indiretta dell'enzima
dell'acetilcolinesterasi si osserva che
c'è un aumento di neurotrasmettitore
quindi questo cosa significa che ci sono
state molte più sinapsi ma non solo
al microscopio quello che vedete qui
questo è un neurone di un ratto nella
condizione arricchita questo
lauro né di un ratto posto nella
condizione impoverita il neurone del
rato nella condizione arricchita ha
prodotto germogli azioni sulle azioni
quindi modificazioni strutturali del
cervello il ratto nella condizione
impoverita non solo non ha prodotto
germogliazione ma addirittura un
impoverimento a livello neuronale quindi
il primo messaggio quale viviamo
vivete in ambiente arricchiti arricchiti
dal punto di vista sociale
non siamo animali sociali abbiamo
bisogno dell'interazione così come
abbiamo bisogno del contatto fisico ma
non solo
continuate a circondarvi di stimoli
cognitivamente stimolanti e importante
fare esercizio fisico quello che
sappiamo oggi è che l'attività fisica
soprattutto quella di tipo aerobico
produce un maggior afflusso di sangue si
daranno al cervello e è in grado di
produrre neurogenesi quindi la crescita
di nuovi neuroni quindi ambiente
arricchito sempre stimoli cognitivamente
sfidanti ed esercizio fisico
vi dicevo altri cambiamenti però e noi
possiamo ottenere con la plasticità
cerebrale sono di tipo funzionale
ad esempio noi sappiamo che il cervello
delle persone cieche all area tattile
molto più stanza rispetto a quella che
abbiamo noi ma noi sappiamo anche c'è un
esperimento famosissimo sui tassisti
londinesi un gruppo di studiosi inglesi
ha studiato i taxisti londinesi tassisti
londinesi per prendere la loro licenza
di taxi sta a londra devono studiarsi a
memoria la mappa della città quindi loro
essere in grado di rievocare a livello
topografico tutte le strade di londra
bene studiando il cervello dei tassisti
londinesi si è scoperto che hanno
un'aria dell'ippocampo vi dicevo che la
sede delle nostre memorie e in
particolare l'aria posteriore
dell'ippocampo che è deputata alla
memoria spaziale alla memoria
tipografica nei taxi londinesi
quest'area ha un volume maggiore
rispetto ai compagni e non solo tra i
tassisti il volume maggiore è correlato
al maggior numero di ore trascorse alla
guida del taxi per cui di nuovo più
alleniamo il nostro cervello più riserva
viene chiamata riserva cerebrale noi
siamo in grado di produrre io mi occupo
di neuroscienze in particolare mi occupo
di studiare dei metodi di riabilitazione
per pazienti che hanno avuto danni
cerebrali qualunque tipo quindi lesioni
traumatiche ictus ma non solo anche
pazienti con demenza quindi
neurodegenerazione quello che noi
osserviamo negli studi e che non tutti i
pazienti
reagiscono allo stesso trattamento
nello stesso modo alcuni recuperano
molto altri sembrano non recuperare ha
fatto queste sono le differenze
individuali per un ricercatore la
differenza individuale la variabilità e
terribile perché non riusciamo a
spiegarla
ma finalmente con questi studi sulla
plasticità cerebrale riusciamo a darci
una spiegazione
ovvero se io ho allenato il mio cervello
ho accumulato riserva cerebrale sono in
grado poi di rispondere meglio nel caso
ad esempio di un trauma o di una lesione
perché perché occhio tessuto cerebrale
da regolari o più circuiti sinaptici
alternativi che posso utilizzare per le
nuove strategie per cui questo è un
altro messaggio
la plasticità cerebrale allenare il
nostro cervello ci permette di resistere
meglio all'invecchiamento e ci permette
di essere anche maggiormente residenti
nel caso di malattie cerebrali
anche mio co degenerative oggigiorno non
esiste una cura per la demenza ma noi
sappiamo che se io parto da un cervello
con una riserva cerebrale maggiore avrò
maggiore resilienza nei confronti della
malattia i sintomi clinici si
dimostreranno molto più tardi nel tempo
per cui per un lungo periodo di tempo
la mia qualità di vita sarà maggiore per
cui quello che volevo lasciarmi in
conclusione e vivete la vostra vita in
un ambiente arricchito circondatevi di
persone
abbiate una vita socialmente attiva e
circondatevi
lì cognitivi non smettete mai di
apprendere continuiamo ad imparare
continuiamo a metterci in gioco e
ricordatevi che apprendimento e fatica
per imparare una cosa devo ripetere
esercizio fisico
cerchiamo di fare sempre esercizio
fisico benissimo se andiamo in palestra
magari dell'esercizio fisico di tipo
aerobico significa anche se possa
evitare di prendere la macchina
vado a piedi in bicicletta trovo le
scale c'è l'ascensore prendo le scale
quello esercizio fisico quotidiano
dormite bene questo è importantissimo
perché perché il nostro cervello
funziona sempre anche quando noi
pensiamo di non fare niente
il nostro cervello attivo ma anche
quando dormiamo un altro esperimento
famosissimo e tese io prendo dei ratti e
il segno loro fanno un percorso il rato
dopo un po impara qual è il percorso in
un labirinto più veloce per arrivare al
cibo io registro la loro attività
neuronale e neuroni sparano sparano
finché imparano fra del tracciato
poi io chiudo la merito irati si
addormentano e nella fase del sonno gli
stessi neuroni sparano perché perché
durante il sonno
il nostro cervello prosegue nel
consolidare la traccia non esita quindi
nell'apprendimento quindi dormite bene
ma soprattutto non smettete mai di
tenere allenato è attivo il vostro
cervello
[Applauso]